[Music]
an aussie woman
is fuming that she has been blocked from
her
8.3 million dollar trust fund until she
gets a job that sounds like that's
probably one of the rules
that's one of the rules right that
sounds fair as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
entitled ass
dude eight mil she she considers herself
broke she is uh the australian heiress
to this 8.35 million dollar inheritance
dude [ __ ] her
and punch her in the [ __ ] she just
needs any job
any job that should be you could just
start an llc and not do [ __ ] they're
hiring everywhere everywhere it's not
even any job literally in the trust
because this uh i guess i'll give a full
contest her name is claire brown she
lives in sydney's uh western suburbs and
she can only access this uh amount of
fortune on the condition she either gets
a job or volunteers to contribute to
society so she could just volunteer oh
dude this girl sucks you mean like um
any job money any job any volunteer
and she has a mother one she could
volunteer for the red cross or something
and she could get this money yes damn
she's gonna be a [ __ ] ta
how does she have a kid and she don't
got a job already exactly so the mother
one plans to contest her father's
request in court because she says her
high functioning adhd means she can't
hold the job no it's high functioning
adhd can give you lots of benefits for
certain drugs yeah dude
what are you talking about we all
[ __ ] got adhd and we got a [ __ ]
amazing job she don't got a job she has
a kid but she can afford a lawyer i'm
gonna kill this [ __ ] dude
well she was probably rich her whole
life right is it the lady's fault or is
it her parents fault because they
created that monster but are you the
product of your environment completely
you have free will
i don't know colleen are you a producer
no i don't think so how old is she how
old is she my parents [ __ ] up on me
but i fixed me yeah joe picks himself
you're self-made bro how about that
[ __ ]
so she uh didn't say her if she pleaded
with her family she said quote give me
what is rightfully mine i am suffering
i've been waiting so long for your money
for free please
you know what we should do we should
give the 8.5 million dollars to that
chick who married the doll in brazil
let's do it let's do it good old enough
give that money to that chick someone
married a doll in brazil they all don't
have a job though the yeah the dolls are
dead the doll has a job yeah
i'm a doll
i got a job
why is it that voice though because if i
had like a big ass fortune to give taika
it wouldn't even be on just one
contingency it would be tiered yeah you
know it'd be like as much
as you earn
that starts matching you so that way oh
that's cool so that way it's not like
let's say if i'm a billionaire he can't
just like i don't know do some stupid
ass job and then get a billion dollars
it's like as
you
up your life this stuff matches what
you're doing so but you wouldn't give
him like half a million or like 500
million off top just not i think i'll
ruin them
now i ain't going to give [ __ ] to nobody
like that's what i'm saying like her
parents are still giving her a [ __ ]
easy out they need to stop doing that
[ __ ] because that's not how the world
but that's how easy it is and they're
still that's what i'm saying like it's
like yes it's crazy she literally says
can you please stop the with the whole
me getting a job thing it's not
happening what a fault
alone
loser then you ain't gonna get no
millions of dollars yeah sorry or i
would put challenges you gotta make out
with the beehive that's tight
she's your daughter though does that
mean
that's the first challenge everything
else is really easy just fear factor
this unlocks the first hundred dollars
like i'll do that but not the job no
that's a tight-ass reality show if
producer was smart enough that's what he
would do he would go all right you want
your money this is what you got to do a
series of challenges it's called
inheritance funds little by little a
bunch of just dead parents that just
wanted to get it out at their kids one
last time but if she doesn't do it it
always goes to like a different charity
that's amazing i'm down to start it with
you that's funny
that sounds good i like it then at the
end of it they come out either just
[ __ ] super loser in their face or
they get these life tools i think and
the grand prize isn't provided by the
network
i think i think she could actually
access the money because i want her to
blow it all which she will
she's not going to be able to make more
of it and then i want to see her
downfall and see how she'll get out of
it that's already down
no she's not that down she's like living
fine she's not not really because she's
like please just stop give me what's
mine i want her in skid row yeah she's
not that dumb because she has hope
eight million is hope you need to
destroy your hope joe's method
if she spends it all there's not another
golden egg and it's like you got it all
so what are you gonna do now
be rich no you spent it all it's
temporary dude people can blow through
8.3 million pretty quick if they've
never managed their money absolutely
what does she look like joe can do it in
one investment oh yeah
you want to see me
give me your inheritance i'll blow it
i guarantee you i'll find some crypto
where i can spend eight point three
million on
gangster
so she said uh her father and i'll keep
a thousand of it
her father had accumulated all of his
money pretty much by working as a
successful stockbroker
and provided his daughter with roughly
350
a week in allowance while also gaining
government benefits but wait how does
she qualify for benefits yeah
unemployment
maybe
or maybe in australia it works different
it doesn't matter how much you make it's
just like their system kind of works
yeah really good benefits for
unemployed people really allowance is a
salary yeah 350 bucks a week week bro
whoa man but you know what um australia
has really good gummies like
like if you if you're poor and you just
out there like that's one thing that i
feel like i could survive on is the
sour worms and the gummy worms oh it's
even like infused yeah me too i was like
you talking about regular candy i know
it's not even that deep this was
surviving on sour gummy bears it's like
someone going
australia has the best coke man
that still makes more sense coca cola
that's not eating diet
they have the best bubble gum there
tonight how to be a survivor out there
you know but their gummies are amazing
man i don't know what it is
but the chewy texture is just so amazing
it's so different from here it's all
made in china can you imagine you guys
joe has the most obscure food reviews of
every like country he goes to like in
tulum he's like the donuts man let me
talk about that
australia the gummies oh let me tell you
don't let the don't let the flies bring
you down
that actually adds it's like when you go
to italy don't worry don't even worry
about the pasta
when you're in mexico and there's a man
with a box on his bicycle and he's
rolling around and then you have to stop
him because he opens that
when flies just fly out there's all
these donuts you know it's the [ __ ] and
it's homemade you talk about like the
churros that are like shaped like this
yeah
they're so good man oh man man that's
true and in france the best food out
there what is it italian restaurant
yes
best bro
i bet there's a really good reason for
it a lot of italians
just french food sucks italian food's
better that's why it's just amazing
the best food in france is italian the
carbonara what's the best food in japan
not too sure the chinese the people the
people yeah
the popcorn in japan
the mixed nuts out there forgot about it
so claire has been living off of uh
welfare payments that she had to pretty
much apply for because uh [ __ ] trash
you're trash yeah tell em geo you need
to [ __ ] grow the [ __ ] up yeah but she
has adhd okay so she is high functioning
she can't hear you she has adhd
out married she's married what does her
husband do her wife
was her wife her wife lauren oh don't
put time hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey hey yo i stepped in that one
fork real quick
cancel yeah it doesn't say what it
doesn't say what her wife does but it
just says that they're living off
welfare in order to take care of their
one-year-old claire's partner also
maintained that due to her diagnosis she
struggles to complete daily tasks and
needs a checklist to remind her to do
simple things such as eat that means
she's just stupid yeah bro i got a
checklist too bro i got a job there's a
[ __ ] app in everyone's phone that
it's already [ __ ] embedded in there
as soon as you buy it because we all
literally do that [ __ ] this this lady is
[ __ ] soft why'd you even choose a
partner that has a checklist you're at
the [ __ ] bar trying to meet people
and [ __ ] and you see a [ __ ] lady like
oh buy your drink
amplify the reasons why you need it so
that they don't take it away oh they're
just milking the system yeah because in
australia they have really good benefits
but because you have good benefits you
have really good inspection on if you
deserve it or not so like you got to
fake the [ __ ] out of it so you guys
checklist [ __ ] everywhere ellen yeah
i need a checklist for my checklist
that you can even discern new zealand
versus australia it's impressive i can't
tell the difference like you're from uh
dude
claire's previous job includes working
part-time for autism australia and a
very brief stint as a barista which
lasted one hour
and claire's family
accuses her of using the condition as a
scapegoat including her cousin jimmy who
slammed her efforts as embarrassing she
needs to go get a job i like jimmy
jimmy's cool man yeah jimmy's down to
earth i think i think you should give
the money to jimmy
jimmy it also depends on how long he's
like
how yeah does she have to have the job
is it like as long as she has a job she
has access to the funds as soon as she's
not working then she doesn't have access
i wonder if because that would make
sense
yeah and then she can't get all the
money at once this [ __ ] is trash can't
keep a job for one hour you're [ __ ]
trash you give that [ __ ] to jimmy man
flip all those turn that guy into jay
millions
james
j billy my name's j millians oh deserve
the money
i deserve the money that's so good
[Music]
you